hello in this talk I will demonstrate
the various ways the microcontroller kit
can be used to upload code to a
microcontroller to acquire data from a
color sensor the sensor is connected to
the microcontroller using an I squared C
interface and the microcontroller is
connected to my laptop using a serial
interface
welcome to to my talk I'm super Thomas
I'm the developer of the microcontroller
kit my objective in this talk is twofold
first naturally I want to demo the
sensor but secondly I also want to go I
squared C communication in the using the
microcontroller kit I've given quite a
few talks on the microcontroller kit but
I squared C communication is something
not it's a little bit more involved and
it's not as straightforward as say
blinking an LED or getting an analog
input so in this talk I want to focus a
little bit more on I squared C
communication as well okay first first
let's look at the sensor and also at I
squared C communication this is the
image of that sensor module the actual
sensor itself is that component right
there in the middle so how does this
sense of work so it has this array of
photodiodes some of them are clear some
of them are red filtered some of them
are blue filtered and some of them are
green filtered so the current that flows
through these diodes is proportional to
what it's sensing and for a preset
amount of time these currents are
integrated and the value we get is a
measure of how much of that particular
color color the sensor is seeing now as
far as I squared C is it too small or is
it okay it's okay so I squared C stands
for inter integrated circuit or it's
also called Twi or two-wire interface so
in this protocol communication happens
along two wires one is the SCL or the
serial clock line and the other one is
SDA or the serial data line and and
there is one master device and the rest
are all slave devices the master is
responsible for generating the clock
signal and all the slave devices are
synchronized to that one master to that
to that
clock signal so it's a serial
synchronous communication protocol now
each slave in this configuration has a
unique address a seven bit address so in
one setup you can have up to 2 to the
power 7 or 128 slave devices and each
slave each but the way so the master is
the one that initiates any communication
whether it's reading or writing to any
of the slaves and the master does that
by sending first a start signal and then
giving the slave address on the data
line and then it gives a read or write
one bit read or write to - let the slave
know whether it's going to read or write
from that particular slave so in I
squared C there are I think there are
seven this kind of specifications there
is the start there is the stop there is
the right to slave
there is the read flumps slave there's
an acknowledgement bit there is a non
acknowledgment bit and then the rest are
all data data bytes so the data is like
the the address of a register the value
to read from a register and the value to
write to to a register and so on
so the physical setup I have here
so I have this this sensor here so there
are only two wires again so what so
these the black and red are just the
power lines and then the SCL pin I
connect to the SEL pin on the Arduino
and the SDA - oh this is the SEL and the
other one is the SDA and this one I
connect to my laptop so there are
several ways we can go about doing this
so one of the ways is to use that so the
sensor I bought from actually Adafruit
send it to us so we can use the library
that they provide or we can go a little
more low level and use just the wild
library that comes with the Arduino ID
or we can just start from bottom up so
we can compare these three approaches
and because these are three parallel
approaches there's going to be some
overlap in the code and so I have this
functionality that I'm just going to
reuse in each case so the first thing I
do of course is to is to load this
package and over here I just have this
one Arduino connected to my Mac and I
can identify the port name by just full
by looking at file names of this of this
form then I create a new create an
utility to create a file so what I'm
going to do is in each approach I'm
going to log my inputs into this file
and so at the end the size of this file
is going to tell me how involved my
effort is was in each up in each
approach and then this is the utility to
open the outputs basically put append to
that file and then I get to the actual
communication itself so the data that's
coming back over serial comes comes back
as a start byte a delimiter byte a start
byte than the actual data a delimiter
byte and an end bytes so it's best
explained using actual values so I just
simulated the kind of readings that are
going to come from the sensor so if you
have the three values what's going to
come back from the sensor is this kind
of ASCII codes
and so what parts data does is basically
reassemble those values and then I
create a pie chart so I can do so it
just gives a pie chart of and then I
have this other visualization utility
that that Norton okay so what it does is
if a stream of data has come in it
brought the different red green and blue
levels and also that pie chart above the
pointer the the pie chart of the last
data point and then this is the utility
to open and read from from the Arduino
itself so I first opened a connection to
the device so after I upload the code
the Arduino is basically a like a serial
device so I open a connection to the
device and then I create a scheduled
task which if there is data it it gets
that data it reads that data parses it
and if it's okay it appends it to this
list RGB lists and then I flush the
buffer so there's nothing
straight left there and then finally
this is an utility to remove the tasks
and close the device okay so let's move
to our first approach now so I create
this file and now after I evaluate this
every all the input I evaluate after
that is going to be logged into that
that file so I set a sampling period of
0.05 this is like a design parameter
this worked fine in my case and then
this is the core computation that's
going to be running on the Arduino
itself so if the clear signal is less
than this 3,500 you get it by trial and
error basically the sensor is not seeing
anything and so I said all the channels
is zero basically it's black and if it's
not then I normalize it using the the
clear signal value now I'm I'm going to
use the library so I had to specify the
library path and these are the head of
files that I'm going to use and this is
the data object in that library for that
sensor and then I said go about
initializing that sensor so when I
deployed this code and it's actually
running on the Arduino and when I when I
begin it's going to establish a
communication through that I squared C
interface with the with the sensor and
this is the function to get the raw
values it gets the raw red green blue
and clear values and then the so I
specify my input channels so in each
case it gets it through the external
library code and each one so the first
one returns clear the second one returns
the red green and blue and the output
from the Arduino is the serial output so
this once I have that this is going to
give me the complete microcontroller
specification the target name the files
I include the utilities the
initializations the input and output
channels and at this point I'm going to
upload the code so see you should see
the or dinner or acumen see it like that
okay so so here also it gives me an
indication that it's both generator the
source code and uploaded to target yeah
okay so now I stopped logging into that
file I now open and so at this point the
Arduino started reading from that sensor
and now I open and read a open a
connection to that Arduino and start
reading okay so you can use any program
I'm using again the Wolfram language the
device framework in the Wolfram language
and now I start let's see what it's
seeing okay it's basically not seeing
anything
so so I'm going to take one of these
meaning breadboards it's a you can also
see it up there so you can see what the
individual diodes are picking up and the
net color so you can you you can try
with different colors
and then if I give a white it should all
the channel should pick it up okay so
this was one approach now I'm going to
stop that task and close the connection
to the Arduino okay so now let's look at
the second upload so the first approach
when we use the library a lot of the
internals were shielded from us so now
we have to go a little deep into both
the sensor and also the I squared C
specification so this is the state
machine for the sensor however so there
is a bit called power on if you when you
turn it on it goes into this state I'm
not going to wait this is useful if you
want to conserve power and the sensor is
running off a battery but I'm not going
to do this I'm just going to go from
this state to enable and then it needs
about two point four milliseconds to to
initialize and then and this is the
integration time that I can set yeah so
if we set a high integration time a
greater value will be returned so that's
again a design parameter so what I'm
going to do is go into the idle state
and then get into initialization and
obtain the data and keep looping like
that
so this is just like before I create
this file and I start adding to that
file the same this is the same as before
and now I'm going to set a preset
integration time in the last case I use
50 milliseconds so here also I'm going
to use 50 milliseconds but here I
directly have to write to the register
on that on that sensor so this this
formula here it comes from the datasheet
on so this is that register itself and
when I put in a particular value into
this register this is what what the
integration time is going to be
yeah so yeah so this so so in the data
sheet will tell you how to calculate
these values so if you want a particular
integration time what value should store
in that register and this is the formula
I've used here I'm using the same
integration as 50 milliseconds as before
and that should be the value and then
all these which I use in uppercase the I
squared C address of that slave device
the register address and so on so again
all this look like magic numbers but
they are all in the datasheet yeah I'm
using this enable register I'm using
this a time register the control
register and this are the registers in
which all those values for the clear
clear signal and the red and the green
are stored so these are all the
registers I'm going to use and that's
what I've just copied from the datasheet
onto here okay yeah so I have the enable
register address and these are the bits
the location bit locations where I'm
going to enable it this is the timer
register and this is the value this is
the register where I set the gain to be
four times and this is the date this is
the register where the clear data
starting the low bit and I don't have to
because they all contiguous registers I
just start with the first and it just
goes to the next eight once so this is
the incantation to write data I start
and then I give this command code the
register value and write what I want to
do in that register so when I initialize
this I'm going to use when I initialize
so when I initialize it in the timer
register I'm going to set how much time
I want to integrate how much gain it
should be and then I enable the sensor
and then stop it and then in a loop I
again start I give the address of the
clear data low byte or register and then
I read seven of them and each time I
read I acknowledge the master will
acknowledge that it has received and
then the final read and then I stop okay
so this is the I square see
specification so at this point when it
is running it's going to get these eight
so but we need to know what to do with
these eight bytes and that's why I
created these these functions so for the
clear function so the first data bytes
that that are coming in are for the
clear function and so the first is the
low byte and then I then I shift the
high byte and I do that for all the
other inputs as well so then that will
give me the complete input channel
specification everything is the same
except for the conversion function so
all these inputs get it from the slave
slave slamed slave device and this is
the conversion and as far as the output
of the microcontroller it's a serial
output so this is the same as before the
microcontroller embed code the core
system I want to upload that same target
and these are my input and output
specifications should it finish
uploading so I stopped loving the data
and that's before I start okay it's time
I can use something else
see begin to see the look :
so it's the same as before just
equivalent code yep
and finally we are going to not use the
wire library also we're just going to
get the microcontroller okay to just
generate code from the bottom up so this
is before I create that file now I'm
going to input and the core code is just
the same as before so I just have it as
an icon there so the only difference
between this and the previous one is
that over here I did not use I used the
wire library and over here I am NOT it's
the only difference and just to make
sure we can go through the same process
again I have a green breadboard it
should see the green color
let me okay so so now that we have gone
through these three approaches I wanted
to see what the what the file sizes are
so there are three files so one is the
Wolfram language code itself the other
one is the source code that was
generated by by microcontroller embed
code and finally it's the machine code
that was deployed onto the onto the onto
the microcontroller so you see so if I'm
using the library I have very little
code to write up front but then the
machine code that gets deployed is large
and if I'm using just everything from
the bottom up I can get a really low
code footprint on the on the
microcontroller just as more pain no
gain so this is an applet
people do several things with this color
sensor so this is something I came up it
came up quite naturally to me so when I
was working with the microcontroller
okay typically typically I'm looking at
LEDs and sometimes if I just look at
them for too long you know it strains my
eyes and things begin to appear blurred
so so I realized that I could use this
color sensor with chromaticity plot to
see what colors I was what colors I was
outputting and then see if it was doing
the necessary thing so so this is this
so I already have the code running there
and just like before I'm going to read
the data and parse it yeah so before I
do that I have this where did I put it I
yeah so I have this this Adafruit flora
and there's a code running on it which
sends a range of colors to this neopixel
plug this in I should bring it here so
you can see so you can see that it has a
it's just cycling through a lot of
colors little hard to see okay so now I
can and then I'm going to hold this on
top of this and hopefully it should pick
up those colors
so I know that that's the code that is
running on that other microcontroller I
know that it's cycling through those
those colors okay so to summarize my
talk so in this so in this presentation
I used this TC s3 475 sensor to get the
color and sent it and program the
Arduino Uno to to get the color values
from that sensor and send it over serial
back back so that we can read it using
the device framework so the main so the
main function I used was there's only
this one function in that in that
package in that packet its
microcontroller embed code so it will do
all the the underlying work for you it
automates that whole process it will go
through generating the source code
compiling it and uploading it to the
microcontroller so there is the
documentation for that and also we there
is documentation for I squared C itself
if you want to like set more options and
so on this small documentation there and
of course I used the Wolfram language
for the rest of the tasks especially the
device framework and virtualization and
the dynamic into a interactivity and
other miscellaneous stuff right so I
think that concludes my talk thank you
[Applause]
yeah yeah the sensor yeah so that's yeah
they say that up front so let me go back
see so once we give a request it takes
about two point four milliseconds to
initialize and then we can set how much
time we wanted to keep measuring it so
all that time it's going to keep adding
the current so we can go up to six
hundred and fourteen million seconds so
total just to do one measurement we need
about six hundred and sixteen
milliseconds but yeah but the sampling
period I said is 0.05 right so it's much
higher than higher than that
yes it's just a different effort
eventually it's the same code it's equal
yeah yeah it it's different ways to to
get to those registers on the
microcontroller different mechanisms
yeah yeah so if you look at this see
when it comes down here it's about four
kilobytes and then there are
microcontrollers which have eight
kilobytes four kilobytes so if you want
to squeeze it into one of those you can
squeeze it into a much smaller target
yeah yeah language so one uses yeah one
is it uses the the wiring library that
comes along with with the arduino ide
and the other case the microcontroller
kit is directly writing to the registers
so the other one another library called
the wiring library is writing to the
registers here it's the the final
approach is really bare metal if you
look at the if you look at this
can you see that
so you'll see all these registers okay
so this is start so it's going there to
that register and setting those bits
it's very low level yeah so yeah so you
need that kind of fine grain if you want
to really make the size compact I just
get it asked for the source code yeah
and you can just copy this put it into
the Arduino IDE and compile it from
there and that'll work too they say that
again so yes so under the hood it
generates the source code and deploys it
that's that is hidden from you but you
can extract the source code like this
and copy/paste over to the Arduino IDE
and then inject and then go that route
yeah so the other thing that we missed
is if you have the source code to give
that to microcontroller me to embed that
that we have not done yet
yeah if you want to write your own
source code yeah yeah so yeah if you
want to write like yeah you can start
from the Wolfram language so here when
I'm using the library I'm actually
mixing over here when I'm using the
library I'm actually mixing code I'm
saying which header files to use and so
on so when I'm when you're working with
the library you're you're working with
both the source code and also leveraging
something off the microcontroller gate
but the final approach is completely
from the Wolfram language and this one
is just an interaction between the two
all right all right thank you